cela fait maintenant trente sept ans que
micola par duke travail au barrage de
cazaux vici
[Musique]
37 ans qui le considère comme son bébé
qu'il en prend le plus grand soin mais
le 24 février dernier il reçoit un ordre
particulièrement inhabituelle il doit
trouver un moyen d'élever de 5 mètres le
niveau de la rivière et repine et vite
pour empêcher une immense colonne de
tanks russes de la traversée oui mais
voilà le barrage n'est pas conçu pour ça
cogne à sochaux comme
on a tout envisagé dit il percé un trou
avec une torche ou une scie à béton mais
finalement il a dû se rendre à
l'évidence la seule solution était de
dynamiter il a même indiqué aux soldats
le meilleur endroit où placer les
charges absolue de niche aux tornades
tacna dabo n'ai pas de regret dit-il
c'était nécessaire et ça a marché les
soldats russes ne sont pas passés
le dynamitage du barrage a eu pour
conséquence d'inonder toute la région le
village des mythes yves s'est retrouvée
sous les eaux
des parties entières de l'agglomération
ne sont accessibles que par bateau
[Musique]
heureusement une pompe installée
récemment a permis de faire baisser un
peu le niveau ce qui a permis à cette
nana de se rendre chez elle à nouveau un
retour difficile où les pour la
prochaine dans mon loulou
gaza
capcom nous y étions
j'étais incapable d'y mettre les pieds
dit elle mais mon mari m'a dit que je ne
devais pas pleurer pour des briques et
des vêtements suite la nar craint que
les fondations de sa maison ne soit
affecté des dommages qui pourraient être
permanent mais elle ne souhaite pas en
dire plus par pudeur
notre malheur n'est rien comparé à ceux
qui ont perdu la vie dit elle
n'importe qui dans de telles
circonstances auraient tendance à se
considérer comme un sinistre et a espéré
réparations pour les dommages causés
mais ici les gens voient les choses
autrement et s'ils reconnaissent avoir
souffert de cette inondation volontaire
il pense aussi que c'est est un mal
nécessaire
c'est le cas de rire ory 63 ans le père
de sita n'a bien sûr sa cave et légumes
a été inondé sa vache et son veau ont
failli se noyer
alors il avoue avoir été un peu nerveux
lorsqu'il a vu l'eau se mettre à monter
mais pour lui cela ne fait aucun doute
le sacrifice était justifiée nous
connaissons
[Musique]
bien sûr des médias jouent un rôle
essentiel dans le déroulement des
événements dit il sinon les rustres est
arrivé jusqu à kiev
un sacrifice qui est loin d'être un cas
isolé dès les premiers jours de la
guerre plus de 300 pont ont ainsi été
dynamitée à travers le pays pour
empêcher l'armée russe d'avancé et si
jean françois bélanger radio-canada
d'aimer div